[Musique]
précédemment dans Joueur du Grenier le
test se poursuit contre le diabolique
jeu vidéo takishi challenge pendant ce
temps là Pepito le poupe de l'espace
réserve un billet malin pour Walibi sur
le bon coin mais Joueur du Grenier
soudainement insulté par le jeu qui a
l'air de pouvoir entendre sa voix
heureusement Sébastien le technicien
intervient et permet à Joueur du Grenier
de poursuivre sa mission courage Joueur
du Grenier toi aussi tu iras à Walibi
[Musique]
vous savez ça m'étonne pas que ce jeu
soit pas sorti en Occident en fait parce
que nous pendant que Nintendo of America
nous censur les jeux à la chaîne les
ntres aussi du coup ben parce que nous
les je en Europe il passaient par la
case États-Unis d'abord au Japon pendant
ce tempsl dans Megam man tu pouvais
tabasser des animaux dans Super Mario
RPG Bower te faisait des fucks pendant
que tu pouvais trouver le god de Peach
derrière la cheminée enfin voilà
clairement ils sont moins coincés que
nous sur certains truc bon après tu me
diras quand on compare nos émissions C H
i r
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
s les différences culturelles ça je sais
que vous l'attendez
CHP bref salut tout le monde alors on en
était resté où au dernier
épisode
merde ah oui voilà c'était débile bref
donc après avoir poussé la chansonnette
trois [ __ ] de fois et d'ailleurs je
détaille même pas toute la débilité de
ce passage au karaokeé vous avez une
méga liste de chansons et sur cette méga
liste de chansons il y en a que une
qu'il faut prendre sauf que celle qu'il
faut prendre tu la connais pas et du
coup ça donne ça je peux prendre
celle-là je peux prendre celle-là je
peux prendre celle-là je peux prendre
celle-là
non bref après que l'ôesse de barre a
appelé des yakuzaas pour me tuer il y a
des yakuzaas partout dans ce jeu même
dans les boulangerie c'est ouf voilà
donc en récompense un vieux sage
japonais vient me donner une carte au
trésor je suis visiblement d'après le
dialogue le seul capable de déchiffrer
cette carte euh sur quel
critère vous voulez vous battre ou quoi
là ah
il est parfait c'est
l'élu bon alors j'ai la carte donc j'ai
le choix j'y mets le feu je la trampe
dans l'encre je la trampe dans l'eau ça
fera un escargot
touch c'est de manga je fais ce que je
[Musique]
veux bon sérieusement donc voilà j'ai
une carte au trésor Ster ça veut dire
regarder je pense que ça me semble être
un bon début pas trop risqué avant de
faire n'importe quoi
attends est-ce que je suis en train de
rêver là non ma console a plé c'est pas
possible où est-ce que mon personnage
est en train de regarder la carte
jusqu'à la mort c'est une blague là
c'est c'est c'est de l'Art nouveau là
s'il vous plaît [ __ ] je je peux je
peux rien faire j'appuie sur tous les
boutons ça fait plus rien dites-moi
qu'on rigole [ __ ] non non non non non
je suis sérieux c'est ma tête sérieuse
ok je n'ai pas noté le mot de passe
quand le vieux il m'a donné la carte ça
m'a foutu directement sur l'écran des
choix sans possibilité de revenir en
arrière pour noter le mot de passe alors
tu vas tout de suite me débloquer cet
écran parce que j'ai pas envie de tout
me
retaper [ __ ] mais mais [ __ ] quoi la
logique de ce jeu [ __ ]
regardez l'heure s'il te
[Musique]
plaît c'est n'importe quoi on croirait
un gag que tu verrais dans un épisode de
Bob l'éponge je veux dire M c'est
regarder ou c'est fixé enfin bref c'est
un choix normal bordel de [ __ ] là vous
enregistrez que je vais devoir tout me
retaper la chanson le divorce les yakuza
la tequila
[ __ ] je veux pas je je ne veux pas
laissez-moi
laissez-
bon après avoir tout recommencé me
revoilà l'endroit où je dois choisir les
options bon alors regardez non bon alors
partons du principe que ce jeu est
débile donc tremper dans l'encre ouais
bon il [ __ ] le feu oui alors il [ __ ]
le feu c'est complètement con et ce jeu
est complètement con c'est la solution
c'est
[Musique]
bon j'ai perdu ma carte mais c'est pas
très grave ce coupci parce que le vieux
sage a plein je avir une autre carte
parce que c'est con mais l'ancienne je
l'ai cramé tu l'élu vous êtes tous des
élus
merci arrête ça ok d le feu c'était pas
ça alors je vais la trempé dans
l'eau encoreé
[Musique]
maintenant regarde mon
intelligence
bit [ __ ] ça marche c'est un truc de
fou mais comment tu savais qu'il fallait
faire tout ça parce que pour la sortie
de ce jeu Takeshi Kitano avait publié
deux publicités C de pub conten des
indices la première pour passer le
passage du karaokeé la seconde te donner
l'indice comme quoi il fallait hurler
sur la manette pour faire apparaître la
carte la durée de 5 à 10 minutes
représente elle la durée standard de
séchage d'un papier mouillé exposé au
soleil et pour dire B dans le micro tu
as dit ça parce que le nom de scè de
takitan c'est B bi
oui tu es allé sur Internet c'est pour
ça que tu t'es levé que tu es parti
ou bref en route pour le Pacific Sud
donc après un court passage sur une île
pour acheter un fling pour mieux tuer
les indigènes en costume de Colon on
arrive à un autre stade du jeu jusque là
on avait juste la partie débile
maintenant c'est la partie vraiment
relou alors je sais pas si les Japonais
ont un problème culturel avec les Delta
plad mais en général c'est toujours des
moments horribles donc vous avez la
carte maintenant le but est d'arriver
sur une île en évitant les très très
très très gros
oiseaux c'est c'est des pérodaacyes
c'est pas des enfin bon bref bref ce
niveau donc est sous la forme d'un shoem
up tu ne peux que descendre par contre
tu ne peux pas remonter en appuyant sur
O le seul moyen de remonter c'est de
choper les courant devant ascendant
c'est un delta plan c'est logique par
contre il faut faire attention en tirant
à ne pas tirer trop vite de manière à ne
pas tuer le vent c'est logique il faut
aussi d'ailleurs rester relativement
haut dans le ciel afin d'éviter les
montagnes et de mieux pouvoir gérer les
soucoupes volantes qui essaye de te tuer
nique ta mère bref de toute manière ce
passage est juste extrême ement dur tu
sens bien que le jeu il a pas été prévu
pour que quelqu'un arrive aussi loin je
sais pas si c'est fait exprès ou si
c'est moi qui fait de la merde pour
toujours me débrouiller pour passer
entre deux trucs devant sans jamais
pouvoir remonter regarde ça et allez
mange-toi la montagne en plus voilà tu
es content là heureusement ce coup-ci
j'ai pensé à noter le mot de passe he
parce que évidemment tu n'as qu'une
seule vie dans ce jeu bah attends c'est
réaliste quand même et c'est long ce
passage que c'est long et ça fait mal
aux oreilles [ __ ] écoutez ça
on doit être proche là de la barrière
des ultrasons là tous les chiens de mon
quartier ils sont en train d'aboyer
chaque fois que je joue à cet
étron mot de passe non non non non non
pas assez de recul merde mot de pas quo
que non tiens regarde une grande
tornnole dans la gueule du mec qui fait
les mot de passe tiens voilà ça fait
gamover mais ça valait le coup bon bref
en admettant que vous réussissiez à
passer ce passage vous allez arriver une
partie du jeu où d'abord en réalité je
vous conseille d'enlever les objets
tranchants ou coupant qui sont à votre
proximité on sait jamais donc il faut
atterrir sur la 4è île et attention la
4è île hein et pas la première la
deuxème ou la troème parce que vous
pourriez le faire si vous en avez envie
mais si vous le faites vous arrivez sur
une île où vous êtes coincé c'est fini
c'est la fin du jeu vous pouvez
redémarrer la console on serait dans un
autre jeu très certainement que je me
serais attardé dessus que j'aurais rallé
que je machin mais on a tellement
atteint le plafond de la connerie bon
voilà au moins donc je suis sur la bonne
île alors donc on va rentrer ici par
exemple
il y a que dal très bien il y a rien ici
rien par là bon et ben je me je me casse
pourquoi pourquoi je peux pas me casser
non pourquoi je peux pas sortir là
attends attendsends non non non non tu
vas pas me faire ça le jeu non tu vas
pas me faire ça tu vas pas me faire ça
la con de toi je peux pas sortir
pourquoi pourquoi je peux pas sortir il
y a marqué exit il y a marqué exit il a
marqué exit il marqué exit là il a
marqué exite et pourtant tu as beau
appuyer sur tous les boutons il y en a
aucun qui marche bon attends du calme on
panique pas et on utilise le mot de
passe alors alors voilà
je le mot de passe il me fait le mot de
passe il me fait recommencer à
l'intérieur du bâtiment où je suis
coincé c'est fini là je suis
définitivement coincé alors que j'ai
rien fait d'autre que de rentrer dans
dans une maison qui ressemble à toutes
les autres maisons en merde [ __ ] mais
c'est c'est c'est quoi le message
derrière ça là ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire qu'il faut pas rentrer chez les
gens comme ça sans prévenir c'est
regardez ils auraient pu te tuer ils
auraient pu te laisser un message du
genre vous êtes enfermé ici à jamais
vous avez plus qu'à éteindre la console
mais non non il te laisse en VIIe il te
laisse en vie et il t'en mis un bon gros
panneau exit et une bonne grosse [ __ ]
de fenêtre qui fait trois fois la taille
de ton perso juste histoire de te
laisser un minuscule espoir de sortir
regarde ça ta mère là tu la vois la
fenêtre ouverte là avec le ciel bleu le
plus bleu que tu as jamais vu tu le sens
là le courant d'air de la liberté qui
caresse ta joue alors que tu es enfermé
comme un débile [ __ ] de merde c'est
comme posé un Big Mac devant un mec qui
a pas de bras c'est clairement une forme
de torture mentale là c'est qui qui a
développé ce jeu c'est des agents de la
CIA c'est pas possible quoi ce jeu il
devait être vendu en grande surface en
en pharmacie à côté des médicaments
contre la chiasse mais j'en peux plus je
meurs laissez-moi crever quoi ce jeu il
m'a tellement fait boire mes larmes que
j'en piss des blocs de sel ah ce jeu il
m'a
[Musique]
battu
grenier
grenier relève-toi grenier loui la
chaussette l'esprit de Noël mais non
espèce de crétin je suis Virginie le
dieu la doubleuse française d'athéa oh
le con je suis la déesse Athena
relève-toi chevalier tu as plein d'amis
qui comptent sur
[Musique]
toi allez c'est reparti même si
maintenant pour moi c'est clair que ce
jeu n'est pas mal fait parce qu'il est
mal fait pour moi maintenant c'est
évident que ce jeu il est mal fait parce
que les gens qui l'ont programmé ont
Siam voulu être des connards avec les
joueurs c'est clair et net et en même
temps je me demande quand même s'il y a
pas un morceau d'incompétence derrière
la méchanceté parce que le gameplay de
ces parties à pied il sent vraiment la
merde de dimanche dernier je veux dire
tenez quand je me baisse il continue à
tirer comme si j'étais debout par le
chapeau voilà et du coup ben je peux pas
tirer sur les animaux au sol ben génial
voilà bon heureusement le tattoo
apparemment là il me fait rien c'est ah
pardon j'ai rien dit le tatou il me tue
mais seulement quand je suis en l'airin
c'est normal les tatou sont plus danger
dans le ciel comme tous les animaux
volants les tatou les les les chimpanzés
les bref donc je suis sur une île et
maintenant je dois rentrer donc dans la
4è maison maison qui a exactement la
même tête je rappelle que les maisons
dans lesquelles tu rentres et tu restes
coincé hein bon bref j'en ai juste plein
le cul donc passons vite là-dessus que
je puisse aller me tirer une balle à la
tête si vous permettez donc en arrivant
dans la maison un mec vous capture et
veut vous bouffer là vous avez plusieurs
choix et évidemment la bonne réponse
était de de sortir la guitare pendant
qu'on cuit et de jouer de la guitare
pour l'attendrir attention écoutez
bien c'est tellement c'est tellement
beau que quelqu'un me tue par pitié bref
donc le mec vous indique l'entrée de la
caverne au trésor regardez vous voyez
elle est là vous voyez cette montagne où
on peut pas monter dessus et ben il y a
un pixel invisible sur lequel tu peux
monter dessus quoi qu'est-ce qu'il y a
bref vous rentrez dans la grotte grotte
dans laquelle vous ne pouvez tuer aucun
ennemi hein parce que je rappelle qu'ils
sont trop bas et donc vous abusez de la
technique du select alors la technique
du select c'est quoi bien c'est une
technique que j'utilise depuis quasiment
le début du jeu et que tu es obligé
d'utiliser pour avancer d'ailleurs tous
les gens et les autres testeurs qui ont
parlé de ce jeu l'utilisent aussi en
général quand tu appuies sur Select ça
fait resette le placement des ennemis et
forcément c'est une technique que tu es
obligé d'utiliser parce que ta ki s'est
dit tiens regardez le dernier niveau on
va remplir toutes les salles avec
uniquement des ennemis qui sont trop bas
pour les toucher ça va être marrant non
enfin bon c'est pas très grave ça fait
juste reboucler la musique toutes les
secondes et demi mais bon après 4 ans de
JDC ce genre de truc n'a plus aucun
impact sur notre santé mentale n'est-ce
pas Seb ouais c'est clair tu es ridicule
et voilà maintenant c'est la dernière
salle salle qu'on accède en appuyant sur
bas au milieu de rien c'était la
dernière insulte de ce jeu envers vous
maintenant je suis arrivé ici j'ai tué
mes enfants j'ai battu ma femme j'ai
démissionné je me bat contre des yetis
des squelettes des pirates des pizzas
bleus des Scorpions roses des tatou
volant des feu follés mais je vais finir
cette merde l'ultime merde du Japon B
peu importe si je dois me battre contre
des robot ninjas pilotés par des lolis
de 12 ans avec des couettes bleu je vais
finir ce jeu
allez je m'en fous j'ai le mot de passe
de la salle je recommence pas au début
allez allez gr vasy quasiment impossible
mot de
passe en a partout il y a des ennemis
partout on cro toi grenier
[Musique]
grenier trésor le trésor
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez
allez ah merde c'est
fini vous savez avant de lcer ce jeu
j'avais entendu une légende comme quoi
Takeshi Kitano le designer de ce jeu
détestait les jeux vidéos mais non c'est
vrai il détestait vraiment les jeux
vidéos c'est pas une légende et en soi
finalement ça explique tout ce jeu n'est
pas horriblement énervant ce jeu a été
conçu pour être horriblement énervant il
y en a eu d'autres depuis he surtout
depuis l'arrivée du net iwaby the guy
cat Mario mais lui c'est vraiment le
premier jeu qui a été créé pour se
[ __ ] de la gueule des joueurs et tous
les mécanismes du jeu reposent sur le
fait qu'ils ont réfléchi à comment vont
réagir les joueurs pour mieux les piéger
ça se voit dans le fait que ce jeu peut
être ou terriblement débile ou parfois
cruellement logique tenez par exemple si
vous arrivez sur les îles du Pacifique
sans avoir appris à parler la langue
locale vous êtes bloqué sur place parce
que vous ne comprenez pas ce que les
gens vous disent ouais c'est
complètement logique ouais mais ce genre
de trucs qui sont beaucoup trop logiques
pour un jeu vidéo surtout à cet époque
ben tu vas les trouver à côté d'autres
trucs complètement cons du genre si
jamais tu n'as pas tabassé le petit
vieux qui donne la carte ben il
réapparaît à la toute fin pour te voler
le trésor ce jeu est un troll et cette
fin là que vous voyez elle est du
même tu t'es vraiment fait chier pour
finir ce jeu de merde bouffon ok le
prends pas trop au sérieux non mais
[ __ ] mais fous-moi la paix je t'ai
battu le jeu je t'ai aïe
péito ça n'est pas possible tu ne
pouvais pas te contenter de mourir mais
péito il n'y a pas de Pepito mon vrai
nom est granolax
au
secours en même temps dans les mangas
les fin c'est souvent pas terrible he
c'est vrai de toute façon je préfère les
com salut c'est
Athéa on m'a dit de conclure l'épisode
mais j'ai pas le texte alors c'est
réalisé par ces trois
là merci Nico au son et Yanque pour le
générique j'aime bien ce générique c'est
blanc sur fond noir c'est original on
dirait du garamon c'est du garamon non
j'aime bien la
Tipo c'est moi là coucou ah ça change
oui abonnez-vous à la chaîne c'est bien
le cosmos c'est bon ah c'est NES blog
j'aime bien Ruf moi